ORDER I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS WE
TRANSITION FROM THE PREVIOUS
HEARING AND SINCE WE'VE ALREADY
DISPENSED WITH THE EXPLANATION
OF OUR PANDEMIC PROTOCOLS AND
EARLIER HEARING I WILL BEGIN
NOW WITH THE TELECONFERENCE
INSTRUCTIONS SO FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT'LL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AS IT IS RIGHT NOW AND
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS
NINE TWO FOUR ONE FOUR FIVE
EIGHT. AGAIN THAT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS
NINE TWO FOUR ONE FOUR. FIVE
EIGHT. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LAN AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. AND
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR- ACCOMMODATING
THAT. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE ONLINE TOOLS.
SO AGAIN PLEASE BE PATIENT SO
EVERYONE WILL GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD. ALSO
ON BEHALF OF OUR STENOGRAPHER
FAINA. I WILL ASK ALL SPEAKERS
COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES ALIKE
TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY.
AND I WILL REMIND. OCCURS
WITNESSES TO SPEAK SLOWER
SHOULD WE NEED TO ACCOMMODATE
OUR STERN ARMOR FOR. THE
SECETARY- ACTUALLY- YOU SHOULD
CALL THE ROLL AGAIN MADAM
SECRETARY. EIGHT YOUR FAITH
HERE HERTZBERG YOUR PREFERRED
HERE LAYERED HERE HERE HERE
WELL HERE LOOK HERE ATKINS HERE
LET ME ASK SENATOR BATES TO GO
AHEAD AND AGAIN FOR THE RECORD-
INDICATE ANYONE WHO MIGHT BE
WITH HER TODAY. JOINING ME
TODAY AND MY DISTRICT OFFICES
RHONDA REARED IN MY STAFF THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES- WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE- WE HAVE THE AGENDA
BEFORE US IF WE COULD I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE ITEM NUMBER TO THE
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE LEGISLATIVE
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE AND ASK FOR A
MOTION. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED- MADAM SECRETARY WE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM TO THE
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE. EIGHT I AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HI THERE HI ARE
YOU WILK HI I ATKINS HI I CAN
SIGN THANK YOU THAT PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY WE WILL BEGIN WITH
OUR FIRST GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE
AMOS J. C. K. COOPER STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES LET ME SAY
WELCOME MISS COOPER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- WE LOVE FOR
YOU TO BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF- TELL US- IF. YOU WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE WITH YOU
TODAY OR JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
ANYONE IN THOSE INTRODUCTIONS
OPENING COMMENTS ARE AND THEN I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE WILL START-
THAT THE CONVERSATION WELCOME.
GREAT THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT IS AN HONOR TO SIT
BEFORE YOU TODAY AS THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERS CONFIRMING
ME AS THE STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE IF YOU
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY MY
HUSBAND BRAIN COOPER- WHO HAS
BEEN BY MY SIDE IN LOVE AND
FRIENDSHIP FOR OVER TWENTY TWO
YEARS MY DAUGHTERS KENNEDY AND
BILLY MY SON'S POLO AND GUY. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
PARENTS FAMILY MENTORS AND
FRIENDS FOR THEIR UNWAVERING
SUPPORT WISDOM AND GUIDANCE
OVER THE YEARS I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
SECRETARY GALLEY FOR AFFORDING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN
THIS ROLE AND LASTLY I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE TEAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN IN I AM INCREDIBLY
PRIVILEGED TO WORK WITH SUCH AN
AMAZING AND DEDICATED TEAM AT
EVERY POINT IN THIS YEAR THEY
HAVE DEMONSTRATED RESILIENCE
CREATIVITY AND STRENGTH- ALL
WITH THE OBJECTIVE OF
MAINTAINING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OVER THIRTEEN MILLION.
PEOPLE SERVED IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. AS THE DEPARTMENT FOR
AHEAD IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
ARE FOCUSED ON TELLING HEALTH
DISPARITIES. AND CODE NINETEEN.
ALLEN STANDS FOR CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING AND INNOVATING MEDIC
CAL THERE ARE THREE PRIMARY
GOALS IDENTIFYING AND MANAGING
MEMBER RISK IN NEED FOR A WHOLE
PERSON CARE APPROACHES AND
ADDRESSING SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH. MOVING MEDIC CAL TO
MORE CONSISTENT AND SEAMLESS
SYSTEM BY REDUCING COMPLEXITY
AND INCREASING FLEXIBILITY AND
IMPROVING QUALITY OUTCOMES
REDUCING HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
DRIVING DELIVERY SYSTEM
TRANSFORMATION FOR VALUE BASED
INITIATIVES MODERNIZATION OF
SYSTEMS AND PAYMENT REFORM. THE
STATE IS LARGE AND DIVERSE IS.
SOME COUNTIES ARE THE SIZE OF A
LARGE HIGH SCHOOL AND SOME ARE
LARGER THAN SOME OTHER U. S.
STATES. THAT IMMENSE VARIETY
HAS MEANT THAT CALIFORNIA
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES HAVE
OFTEN BURIED COUNTY TO COUNTY.
STANDARDIZING SERVICES AND
ACCESS ACROSS THE STATE
PRESENTS CHALLENGES BUT IT IS
NECESSARY TO GIVE OUR RESIDENTS
IN A CONSISTENT STANDARDIZED
SET OF COMPREHENSIVE BENEFITS
THAT THEY CAN COUNT ON AN
ACCESS NO MATTER WHERE THEY
LIVE INCLUDING ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING
COMMUNITY BASED CARE MANAGEMENT
IN A ROBUST SET OF SUPPLEMENTAL
SERVICES LIKE HOUSING SUPPORTS
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
RESPITE AND RETRIBUTIVE CARE.
AS A KEY PART OF OUR VISION TO
DRIVE DELIVERY SYSTEM
TRANSFORMATION FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE BENEFICIARIES. SUCH
AS HOMELESS JUST AS OF ALT ROCK
ARE YOU AN AGING POPULATION
JUST TO NAME A FEW. FURTHERMORE
THE CODE NINETEEN HAS
DISPARITIES AND SYSTEMIC RACISM
IN SOCIETY AND IN THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEGUN TO ANALYZE
VARIOUS HEALTH INEQUITIES TO
DEVELOP A ROADMAP TO ADDRESS
SUCH OUTCOMES. AND FINALLY WITH
THE IMPACT OF CODE NINETEEN WE
MUST WORK TO PRESERVE A NETWORK
OF CARE IN A DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT CARE ENVIRONMENTS WE
ARE FOCUSED ON ENSURING
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES RECEIVE
THE COVETED NINETEEN VACCINE A
SHIFT TOWARDS TELEHEALTH
ADOPTION AND HOW WE ENSURE
CONTINUED QUALITY. INCREASE
ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS
AND SAFE LONG TERM CARE
ENVIRONMENTS AND ADDS PEOPLE
START TO ENGAGE WITH THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM AGAIN. CATCHING UP
ON MISSED CHILDREN
IMMUNIZATIONS PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES AND DELAYED CARE FOR
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. ARE
BENEFICIARIES OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE TO ME AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU AND WE AS WE ADVANCE IN
INNOVATE MEDIC CAL REDUCE
HEALTHCARE DISPARITIES.
INCREASE ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AN ONLINE FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND I
HAVE I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MISS COOPER WITH THAT I'M GOING
TO. GO AHEAD AND GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND I WILL SENATOR
BATES- START WITH YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND-
CONGRATULATIONS ON SAFETY YOUR
DISCO GIRLS GEZI AND BURST
STARTING. AT OUTSIDE DOWN THERE
BUT JOBS YOU GRADUATION SIGNED
GOING ARE VERY VERY JOB I WILL
SHARE WITH YOU THAT I WAS ONE
OF THE ORIGINAL SUPERVISORS
WITH THE US DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES. WHEN
THEY STARTED MEDICARE ALSO THAT
AGE YOU KNOW I'M REVEALING MY
AGE BUT EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
ANYWAY SO I'M THE INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW THE PROGRAM
WAS SOLD VERY VITAL- BACK IN
THOSE DAYS WHEN IT WAS BROUGHT
FORWARD. AND CERTAINLY HAS
GROWN HAS PROVIDED SOME
INCREDIBLE MANIFEST YOU BILLS
ARE LOWER INCOME IN PARTICULAR-
HEALTH PLANS DO HAVE A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NEW
PRESCRIPTION BACK THAT. SERVED
US BOB THAT'S TO BE INITIATED
AND HOW SHE PLAN. ODD YOU KNOW
SHARE WITH US WHAT I YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT BECAUSE- THE
DELAY THAT ON IS OUR I GUESS IN
THE WAR. FOR A CUP OF MONTHS IS
UP. CHIU DAHLE HELP AND UP YOU
CAN ARGUE US ON MAYBE IT COMES.
ANJO WE ARE MAYBE REDUCE THE
KINDS. THAT HE ABOUT NOT PLAIN
GOING TO BE ON. FIVE HAVE SAID
ELSE CURRENTLY PARTICULAR
BELIEVE THAT APRIL THE YOU'RE-
YEAH SO THIS YEAR YOU THOUGHTS
ON THAT BOB CERTAINLY YOU'RE
BACK. YOU HAVE MY- BUT I THINK
THESE IMPORTANT THINGS TO DO ON
A RACK NOW. IF OU'RE GETTING
THE LET JUST PROPERTY INCOME.
THE WILL BE UP. SHE GREW THAT.
RIGHT THANK YOU. YES THE DEPART
DID- TO THE TRAIN. TO MEDICARE
LARACH FROM JAN FIRST TWO TWO.
FOR WE REALLY DID IT BECAUSE OF
THE KOBE. AROUND THE STATE A
CALIFORNIA AND THIS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HOW THE IT WAS NAY.
TO MAKE SURE THE HOW BILL
SYSTEM COULD BUT ARE AT. WERE
THAT SURGED- WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT I PROVIDE WERE BY
INFORMED ABOUT THE- GIVEN THAT
DELAY WE HAVE DONE A NUMBER OF
THINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT
PROVIDERS PLANS AND
BENEFICIARIES OR WHERE. SO WE
DID STILL ON JANUARY FIRST
LAUNCH OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE
CENTER FOR EXAMPLE IT'S LIVE
TODAY- WE LAUNCHED OUR PROVIDER
PORTAL SO. PLANS PROVIDERS
BENEFICIARIES CAN GET IN THERE
AND GET USED TO WHAT THE SYSTEM
WILL LOOK LIKE EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVEN'T TRANSITIONED. UP WE
ALSO. HAVE BEEN ROLLED OVER I
THINK WE'RE CLOSE 293% OF ALL
PHARMACIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE NOW BEEN
ENROLLED TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM SO.
THAT'S A LOT OF- ENROLLMENT.
VERY PROUD OF THAT- AND WE ARE
ALSO WORKING TO GET VERYONE IN
THE PORTAL AND TRAINED THE NICE
THING WITH THE EXTENDED
TRANSITION PERIOD IS THAT CAN
GET INTO. THE- FOR IT WE HAVE A
PROVIDER DIRECTORY ONLINE TO A
BENEFICIARY CAN GO IN AND
SEARCH WHERE THE PHARMACIES
WITHIN OUR NETWORK THEY CAN
READ THE MANUAL IF THEY'RE SO
INTERESTED IN THAT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT DRUGS RECOVERED
CETERA. SO WE REALLY TRIED TO
EXPAND EDUCATION IN THIS TIME
OF THE TRANSITION- AND MAKE
SURE THAT PROVIDERS IMPLANTS
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS
POSSIBLE CAMANCHE. ON APRIL
FIRST AT THIS IME WE ARE STILL
FULLY ANTICIPATING ON THE APRIL
ONE GO LIVE I MEAN WE'LL DO
WHAT WE CAN TO ENGAGE WITH OUR
PROVIDERS OUR PLANS AND OUR
BENEFICIARIES- TO BE READY FOR
THAT TRANSITION. RIGHT GREED
HERE THAT AND SHOULD THE PLANS
AREN'T ABLE TO HEAR THAT YOU
SELL. GOOD LUCK TO YOU AND
AGAIN WE ARE A RESOURCE
WHENEVER I NEED ASK THAT BUT
YOU. IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT OUR
STATE. SOME BILLS AND SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO CALLER
HEALTHCARE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO BATES- SENATOR. THANK
YOU MATT CHAIR I THINK THAT ARE
OF GOOD- OF ZOOM WITH MISS
COOPER. AND RIGHT. JUST GIVEN
THE RIGHT THIS OF THE HEARING
LET ME JUST BRIEFLY NAMES SOME
OF THE THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT
WHERE I THOUGHT SHE HAD A
STRONG COMMITMENT BECAUSE OF
THE COMMUNITY BASED MANAGED
MEDICAL CARE SHE HAS A STRONG
COMMITMENT TO THOSE ARE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AROUND THE
STATE AND WORK WITH SOME
RECOGNIZED THAT THEY ARE NOT
JUST COST EFFECTIVE BUT MUCH
BETTER CARE. ON THE ISSUE OF
HEALTH DISPARITIES WHICH SHE
MENTIONED IN HER OPENING
STATEMENT HE'S VERY AWARE THAT
RATHER THAN JUST TAKING THE
SYSTEM AS IT CALMS THAT THE
SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE WORKED. TO
BETTER ADDRESS HEALTH
DISPARITIES. AND JUST GIVEN THE
THIRTY MILLION PEOPLE SHE KNOWS
THAT THERE HAVE TO BE SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS AND THAT THERE'S
JUST BASIC MANAGEMENT THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND SHE SEEMED
AS- A WITH THE OVERLAY OF
COVERED RIGHT NOW. SHE SEEMED
TO HAVE A GRASP OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE STRONG A REAL
COMMITMENT AND JUST EXUDED
CONFIDENCE ALLTHE WAY THROUGH
I JUST THINK IT'S GOOD TO PUT
THAT ON THE RECORD I'M GONNA BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT HER
CONFIRMATION. SENATE EARLIER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM IN A CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT JUST- JUST ONE
REALLY QUICK QUESTION- THE
STATE AUDITOR RECENTLY- RELEASE
REPORT ON PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS
IN PART OF HIGHLIGHTING THE DHS
CS IS NOT ESTABLISH ADEQUATE
CONTROLS OVER THE DISTRIBUTION
OF THOSE FUNDS. PURCHASE OF IF
YOU COULD SHARE WITH US YOUR
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE AUDITOR'S
REPORTS IN WHAT WAYS IF ANY CAN
WE RETHINK THE PROGRAM TO
BETTER PROVIDE SERVICES. THANK
YOU SO PROPERTY SIX HAS BEEN-
AN IMMENSE- A PROGRAM IN THE
MEDIC HOW. PROGRAMS REALLY
BEING ABLE TO GET SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS TO PHYSICIANS TO
DENTISTS- FOR NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION FOR HOME
HEALTH SERVICES IT'S BEEN VERY
CRITICAL FOR US TO HAVE AN INCH
IMPLEMENT. ONE OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT IS IN ON THE PROP FIFTY
SIX IS THE- LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM FOR PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS. AND I BELIEVE THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE REFERENCING IN
REGARDS TO THE AUDIT REPORT I'M
ONE OF THE- CORNERSTONES OF THE
PROPERTY SIX DOLLARS IS TO
INSURE THAT WE ARE GIVING LOAN
REPAYMENTS DEPOSITIONS AND
DENTISTS AND- I'M HARD TO
ACCESS AREAS OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WE HAVE VERY MUCH DONE SO
HOWEVER IT'S NOT THE ONLY
MEASURE THAT WE HAVE HAVE USED
FOR ON DETERMINING WHICH
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS WE NEED
IN OUR PROGRAMS- IT ALSO. OF
THE FOCUSED ON CLOSING GAPS ON
CERTAIN SUBSPECIALTIES FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE PARTS OF THE
STATE WITH VERY LOW ACCESS TO A
PEDIATRIC SUBSPECIALTIES-
HOWEVER THE POSITION MAY RESIDE
IN A LARGE URBAN AREA- BUT
PROVIDING ACCESS VIA TELEHEALTH
AS WELL AS OTHER MODALITIES- TO
BENEFICIARIES ACROSS OUR
PROGRAM- AND SO WE HAVE LOOKED
ACROSS GAPS. ON CERTAIN
SPECIALTIES- WE HAVE LOOKED AT
YOU THAT GEOGRAPHICAL GAPS- AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAXIMIZE
AND DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
UTILIZE THE PROPERTY SIX FUNDS
TO. NOT ONLY INCREASE THE%
PAYMENTS TO OUR PROVIDERS AND
OUR DENTISTS AS WELL AS DIRECT
THOSE LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS.
TO THE MOST NEEDED AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA. APRIL YOUR ANSWER
AND LOOK FOR TO FOR COMFORT.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- MR MAJORITY
LEADER THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN
THE HOME HOPING IN THE POST
COLD WORLD- WE'VE USED
TELEHEALTH PRETTY SUCCESSFULLY
NOW FROM EVERYTHING I CAN
UNDERSTAND IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON WHAT OPTIONS YOU
PATIENTS WILL HAVE WHO ENJOYED
THE BENEFITS OF TELEHEALTH IN
THAT IT WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THAT. SERVICE THANK
YOU YOU ARE CORRECT WE HAVE
SEEN EXPONENTIAL GROWTH AND
TELEHEALTH UNDER CODE NINETEEN-
AND THAT IS- THAT IS EXCITING I
THINK THAT IT IS A VERY GOOD
AND USEFUL MODALITY ACROSS ALL
DELIVERY SYSTEM SO ACROSS OUR
PHYSICAL HEALTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- WE'VE EVEN SEN GREAT
EXPANSIONS DURING COATED- UNDER
THE LONG TERM SERVICES ANDSUPPORTS IN OUR- COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES. OF WHICH IS
CRITICAL ON THE DEPARTMENT I
WILL BE RELEASING A TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL- NEXT WEEK- BURKE
CONSIDERATION AND IT IS LOOKING
AT EXPANDING AND KEEPING IN
PLACE SOME OF THE TELEHEALTH
MODALITIES. GIVE ME. THAT WERE
IN PLACE AN EXPANDED UNDER
COVER NINETEEN INCLUDING ACROSS
ALL OF THOSE DELIVERY SYSTEMS
THE PHYSICAL HEALTH EXPANSION
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH EXPANSION-
EVEN LOOKING AT SOME OF OUR
COST BASED REIMBURSEMENT-
TARGETED CASE MANAGEMENT. AS
WELL AS COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED
FOR THAT PROPOSAL TO COME OUT-
AND WE DO THINK THAT IT WILL
HELP I'M PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
FOR BOTH PROVIDERS AND
BENEFICIARIES OF WHILE ALSO-
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT. CONTINUED
QUALITY OF CARE AS WELL AS
PATIENT CHOICE WHICH IS REALLY
CRITICAL PATIENTS YOU STILL
HAVE THE ABILITY- TO REQUEST IN
PERSON CARE IF IT THAT SO WHAT
THEY CHOOSE- AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THAT PROPOSAL
WHEN IT IS RELEASED- AND I.
IMAGINE IT WILL BE ABLE TO HELP
MANY PEOPLE AND INCREASED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
LAST QUESTION ABOUT YOUR
PHARMACY PROGRAM THE
TRANSITIONING. BALL MEDICAL
PHARMACY BENEFITS FOR MANAGED
CARE TO FEE FOR SERVICE.
OBVIOUSLY EVERY MONTH PEOPLE
NEED O GET THEIR DRUGS. DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INTERFACE
BETWEEN HOW YOU MAKE THAT
TRANSITION HE THOUGHTS ON HOW
CONSUMERS WILL BE INFORMED. OF
THE NEW PHARMACY BENEFIT
BENEFITS AS THEY SEEK TO. YOU
KNOW ON EVERY MONTH TO GET THE
DRUGS. A MEDICARE ARE EX OF
TALKING ABOUT. I'M DO YOU MEAN
I'M SORRY THERE WAS A SLIGHT
INTERNET CONNECTION I'M SORRY.
CAN YOU REPEAT THE QUESTION
SORRY FOR SOME REASON THE- IN
CONNECTION WAS COMING IN AND
OUT I APOLOGIZE SOON SO YOU
BROWN'S SORRY. NO THE QUESTION
HAS TO DO WITH YOUR THAT THE
MEDICALLY TRANSITIONING IN
MEDICARE ARE EX FOR PHARMACY
PATIENTS AND GOT A MAKING SURE
HOW YOU TRANSITION AGAIN WHAT
THE INTERFACES FOR THE- SO MANY
FOLKS EVERY MONTH NEED TO GET
THERE THEY'RE MET THEIR MEDS
BASICALLY WHAT KIND OF THINKING
HAVE YOU BEEN DOING WITH
RESPECT TO THAT TRANSITION.
SORRY YES THANK YOU. SO AS I
WAS MENTIONING EARLIER ONE OF
THE GOOD THINGS ABOUT MEDIC
CALORIE ACTS IT IS WE HAVE
PROBABLY THE LARGEST FOOTPRINT
OF ACCESS TO PHARMACY PROVIDERS
THAN ANY OTHER NETWORK. SO AS
WE TRANSITION ALL INDIVIDUALS
FOR MANAGED CARE TO- THE
MEDICAL OR EXPERT PLATFORM WE
CURRENTLY HAVE 93% OF ALL
PHARMACIES IN CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY ENROLLED TO
PARTICIPATE. WHICH PRETTY MUCH
MEANS ALMOST ALL PHARMACIES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WOULD BE
ABLE TO USE TO FILL THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS- WE ARE REALLY
ENCOURAGING PROVIDERS TO GET ON
AND ACCESS OUR PORTAL IT'S BEEN
LIVE SINCE JANUARY THAT CAN GET
ON BECOME FAMILIAR WITH IT. WE
ARE OFFERING TRAININGS SINCE
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY A
NUMBER OF WRITERS TO BECOME
FAMILIAR WITH THE SYSTEM THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD LIKE-
AND SO WE- ARE REALLY
ENCOURAGED WITH GETTING THAT
INFORMATION OUT. WE THINK THAT
WILL CREATE GREAT ACCESSIBLE
ALSO STANDARDIZED THE PHARMACY
BENEFITS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
MEDICARE POPULATION. RIGHT NOW
DEPENDING ON WHICH MET A
MANAGED CARE PLAN YOUR IN YOUR
PHARMACY BENEFIT COULD CHANGE
VERY IN REGARDS TO THE SERVICES
NOW WE WILL HAVE ONE STATEWIDE
PHARMACY BENEFIT- WHICH
INCREASED ACCESS TO PHARMACY
SERVICES THAT WE ARE VERY
HELPFUL AND MEDICARE X. COMING
LIVE IN APRIL- AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH PHARMACIES AND
PROVIDERS TO MAKE IT AS
SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE- THANK YOU I
MISTER. LAY I WANT TO I JUST
HAD A QUICK QUESTION- THE
DEPARTMENT RELEASED ITS TWENTY
TWENTY PREVENTATIVE SERVICES
REPORTERS AS REFERENCED- AND-
I. FOLLOWED ALONG I HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS I'M PLEASED
ABOUT THE REPORT BEING DONE IN
RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT OF
PREVENTATIVE SERVICES PROVIDED
TO CHILDREN ENROLLED IN MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS. YET IN
TWO TO TWO POINTS ONE THE
MAJORITY LEADER STARTED. ADDING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
SOMEWHAT RELUCTANT- TO EXPAND
THE USE OF TELEHEALTH-
PERMANENTLY SO- MAYBE YOU
COULD. KIND OF PICK UP ON THAT
AND TELL ME HAS THERE BEEN A
CHANGE OF HEART IS IT NOT TRUE
THAT THERE WAS RELUCTANCE MAYBE.
GIVE A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE
THERE. HAS COULD THINK WE'VE
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
TELEHEALTH IN FACT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN THE
DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY HAD.
GREATLY EXPANDED OUR TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL EVEN BEFORE COBIT
NINETEEN WE HADN'T SEEN THE
INCREASE IN ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH SERVICES THOUGH
INTEL AND TELL THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WHERE IT
GREATLY EXPANDED- AND SO NOW
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IS HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH PROVIDERS
ASSOCIATIONS BENEFICIARIES. A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT ARE THE LONG TERM
MODALITIES THAT SHOULD BE-
AVAILABLE IN MEDIC CAL. AND WE
ARE LOOKING FOR A PROPOSAL THAT
WILL BE RELEASED NEXT WEEK
ACROSS ALL THE MENTALITY THAT
WOULD INCLUDE SYNCHRONOUS.
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEPHONIC AN
AUDIO ONLY- AS WELL AS REMOTE
PATIENT MONITORING WHICH IS
CURRENTLY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO. IMPLEMENT
AND IN MEDIC HOW- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE VARIOUS
TELEHEALTH MODALITIES WILL BURY
ACROSS DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND
PROVIDER TYPES AS APPROPRIATE-
FOR CLINICAL APPROPRIATENESS.
AND THE PAYMENT PARITY OF
MAYBERRY ACROSS VARIOUS
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AS WELL- SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD NOT TELL
HELP PROPOSAL COMES OUT- BUT WE
DO. ANTICIPATE IN OUR PROPOSAL
YOU SHOULD BE EXPECTING THAT IT
WOULD INCREASE ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH FROM WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY- AS WELL AS IMPLEMENTING
MANY OF THE FLEXIBILITIES THAT
ARE IN- IN AVAILABLE DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. THANK
YOU MISS COOPER OF THE LAST
THING- AS PART OF THAT- REPORT.
THE YOUR PREVENTATIVE SERVICES
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN OUT WAS
MENTIONED- AS IT RELATES TO OUR
OUT YOU HAVE YOU SEEN THE
RESULTS OF THAT CAMPAIGN AND-
HOW HAS THE PANDEMIC IMPACTED
THIS AND IT'S SPECIFICALLY
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT KIDS
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE WELL CARE
VISITS A PREVENTATIVE CARE
VISIT. VISITS ESPECIALLY RIGHT
NOW DURING THIS. TIME SO YES
I'D SEEN THE- THE RESULTS. OF
THE REPORT AND- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ERY. WITH
MAY CARE- THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
OUTREACH THEY'VE BEEN SENDING
ON WHAT WE CALL POSTCARDS- TO
BENEFIT YEARS MAKE SURE THEY
KNOW WHAT PREVENTIVE SERVICES
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE TO
HAPPEN. AS WELL AS IF THEY HAVE
AN ACCESS THOSE PREVENTIVE
SERVICES- I WOULD NOTE THAT-
THAT VERY EARLY ON DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WE
IDENTIFIED A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN CHILDREN ACCESSING.
THAT ONLY CHILD CARE VISITS
ABOUT GETTING THEIR CHILD
IMMUNIZATIONS IN PLACE- WE
STARTED. HAVING CONVERSATIONS
VERY QUICKLY IN MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY- BECAUSE OF THE
UTILIZATION DECREASES TO GET
THE WORD OUT TO PEOPLE TO MAKE
SURE THEY UNDERSTAND IT STILL
VERY CRITICAL TO HAVE THOSE
IMMUNIZATIONS TAKING PLACE. WE
ARE WATCHING THE DATA CLOSELY
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE THE
NUMBERS COME BACK UP I'M
HOWEVER WE ARE STILL NEEDING TO
CATCH UP FOR THE MONTHS FROM
ABOUT NOON I WANNA SAY WAS
AROUND MARCH- ALL THE WAY
THROUGH AUGUST SAW SIGNIFICANT
DECREASES. COMPARED TO PREVIOUS
YEARS AND CHILDREN
IMMUNIZATIONS- IN THE END CENTS
OCTOBER WE'RE STARTING TO
REALLY SEE THOSE NUMBERS
INCREASE SO WE WILL BE ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH PEOPLE TO RE
ENGAGE WITH THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. NOW THE OFFICES ARE
OPENING BACK UP- AND HAVING
AVAILABLE APPOINTMENTS WE DO
NEED TO GET THOSE KIDS END OF
THE MANAGED CARE PLANS HAVE
RESTARTED ON THEIR CALL
CAMPAIGNS- AND OUTREACH TO OUR
BENEFICIARIES. WE ARE REALLY
HOPING THAT WE CAN MAKE UP. FOR
SOME OF THAT THAT TIME DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
WHERE. PEOPLE ARE JUST REALLY
HAVING ON TROUBLE GETTING INTO
THE TYPES OF VISITS WE'RE
OFTENTIMES PREVENTIVE SERVICE
VISITS CAN ALWAYS HAPPEN VIA
TELEHEALTH A BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO DO BERRIES COMPONENTS THAT
REQUIRE YOU TO BE IN PERSON
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE GETTING
YOUR IMMUNIZATIONS- AND SO WE
WILL BE VERY FOCUSED ON GETTING
THOSE. NUMBERS UP WE JUST
MENTIONED AT OUR AND CHAP-
MEETING EARLIER THIS WEEK I'M
REALLY FOCUSING AND WORKING
WITH PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
COME BACK IN. AND RE ENGAGE IN
HEALTH CARE AFTER THE PUBLIC
MERCHANTS IN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
COOPER WELL IT LOOKS- I TO LOOK
BACK IT LOOKS LIKE YOU WERE
APPOINTED ON THE THIRTY FIRST
OF JANUARY SO WE'RE ALMOST AT
YOUR ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF
WHAT A YEAR OBVIOUSLY IN THE
BED- WITH A LOT OF CURVEBALLS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THOUGTFUL
RESPONSES TO OUR QUESTIONS I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
MISS COOPER WILL START IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD I DO NOT SEE A MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE SO LET
ME. DO MY DUE DILIGENCE GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. I SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE OZ SO. WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. I TO SEE AND
PICK UP TESTIMONY FROM THERE.
OUR MODERATOR LET ME WELCOME
YOU AND ASK IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF MYSTERY C.
K. COOPER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AGAIN ARE FOR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. THAT'S ONE
NINE ZERO FROM THE TELEPHONE
LINE. CANADA WE FIRST TURNED TO
LINE OF ONE FIVE FIFTEEN THAT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN THANK YOU
IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO THE
WITNESS IF I COULD JUST A
MOMENT THANK YOU- IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY YOU'RE
ASSOCIATED WITH AND POSITION ON
THE APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY SO ARE-
STENOGRAPHER WILL BE ABLE TO
PICK UP YOUR- COMMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GO RIGHT AHEAD.
ABSOLUTELY MADAM CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON- MEMBERS AS WELL
BETSEY ARMSTRONG WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SIXTY ONE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. WE'VE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH MR COOPER DURING
HER TENURE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND I'VE
ALWAYS FOUND HER TO BE
EXCEEDINGLY DILIGENT AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMMATIC ISSUES WE
ENCOUNTER AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN ADDITION WERE EXTREMELY
HEARTENED BY THE DEPARTMENT
FOCUS ON EQUITY AND REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM ON-THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE. AND
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO ENDORSE
HER NOMINATION AND STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISS ARMSTRONG
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. BUT NEXT
WE TURN TO LINE OF ONE TWO ONE
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM REPRESENTING
THE THIRTY FOURTH DISTRICT
FIFTEEN AT THE HOSPITAL
CALIFORNIA. IT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUMS HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH MISS
COOPER TO THE BENEFIT OF
CALIFORNIANS PATIENTS. AND WE
APPRECIATE HER DEDICATION TO
HER PER HER POSITION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT ON HER
APPOINTMENT TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
GADO NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
RICHARD KLEIN OF ONE SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ERICA MARIE AND THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT IN ITS- FIRST
NOMINATION I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF KNOWING MISS COOPER AND
WORKING WITH HER FOR I TINK
THIRTEEN YEARS BEGINNING WITH
HER LEADERSHIP AND KERN COUNTY
AND THE COVERAGE INITIATIVE
PROJECT. EXTENDING TO OTHER
MAJOR DELIVERY SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT. ON AND
PARTICULARLY THIS PAST YEAR
WHERE SHE HAS SEEMINGLY WORKS
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN IN RESPONSE
TO THE DAY AT THAT COBIT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC SHE IS AN
EXTREMELY DEDICATED AND
THOUGHTFUL LEADER AND IT'S
HASHING THAT ABOUT ENSURING
THAT MEDICARE PATIENTS RECEIVE
TIMELY HIGH QUALITY AND
EQUITABLE CARE. I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE STATE ARE
WELFARE. BAKER AT THE HELM OF
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM. THEY YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. THE
CREATURE CLYDE OF ONE EIGHT ONE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BARBARA GLAZER WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF JT COOPER FOR
CONFIRMATION AT STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. ENTER A
POINT MAN IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NOT ONLY HAS
SHOWN TO BE HIGHLY ENGAGED AND
CLAPPER GROUP WITH HOSPITALS
AND OTHER HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
IN ENSURING ALL THOSE WHO NEED
HEALTHCARE. ARE ABLE TO GET IT
BUT ALSO INTERPR LEADER HELPING
TO RESPOND AS OF THE NINETEEN
GLOBAL PANDEMIC. EIGHTY PRIOR
EXPERIENCE AS SENIOR ADVISER TO
THE STATE MEDICAID DIRECTOR AND
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM T.
H. YES. BAKER UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED TO BE THE STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR PER
CALIFORNIA. WE READ WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO BE
CONFIRMED AS THE H. THE ESTATE
ADVOCATE DIRECTOR IN CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WITH TURN LINE UP ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ALEXANDRIA DAVIS AND
I'M CALLING WITH LEADING AIDS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT JC COOPER AT THE STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS AT DH CS. IN THE PAST
YEAR WE HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING WITH MISS COOPER ON
VARIOUS ITEMS SHE HAS PROVEN TO
BE THOUGHTFUL COLLABORATIVE
OPEN TO DISCUSSIONS AND VERY
RESPONSIVE TO ALL FEEDBACK WE
ARE HOPEFUL WITH HER LEADERSHIP
THAT SHE CAN HELP STRENGTHEN
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
COMPONENTS BONOBO POPULATIONS.
INCLUDING OUR AGING POPULATION
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. BURKE RICHARD
CLYDE OF ONE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
FRED MAY NOW BE HALF OF ALL
PATIENTS THE STATE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE PROGRAMS OF
ALL INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY AND WE ARE HERE TO
ENDORSE- MISS COOPER'S
APPOINTMENT AS STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE
ON HER. CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
MISTER MAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE TURN TO
I'D OF ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES NUMBER
CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
MISTAKING COOPER WITH A NUMBER
OF SIGNIFICANT HEALTH POLICY
ISSUES WITHIN THE CAR HARTMAN A
FEW MINUTES THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF BOTH THE FEDERAL
AND STATE. OF FUNDING FEEDBACK
LOOP COUNTIES ARE CONFIDENCE
AND WITH WHO BIRTH EXPERTISE IN
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM IS THE
ASSET TO THE STATE BUT IT IS
ONLY HER GOAL AND THEY
INCREASED HEALTH ACCESS
THROUGHOUT COMMUNITIES IS ONE
THAT COUNTY SHARE THE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HER CONTINUED
WILLINGNESS TO PARTNER WITH US
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
RICHARD OF FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY BEING WHAT
HEALTH NET CALIFORNIA. RECEIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION CONFIRMATION OF
GAC COOPER AND EXTEND OUR
CONGRATULATIONS ON HER WELL
DESERVED APPOINTMENT. NEED TO
PRINT IT MINISTRY AND
LEADERSHIP EXPERIENCE WILL
SERVE HER WELL IN ENSURING
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES AND SERVICES THEY
NEED TO LEAD HEALTHY HAPPY AND
PRODUCTIVE LIVES- TRACK RECORD
SHOWS SHE RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF PARTNERING WITH
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. TO
COORDINATE CARE AND IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES WHAT YOUR
VALUES HEALTH NET ALSO PULLED
AT THE GOLD STANDARD. OKAY LOOK
FORWARD TO COLLABORATING WITH
MISS COOPER ON UPCOMING
MEDICARE REFORM INITIATIVE. TO
IMPROVE CARE FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONFIRM HER APPOINTMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER CRAWLERS IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR WE
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A
MOMENT. I'M GOING TO BRING IT
BACK INTO ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE AND SEE IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
HERE IN OPPOSITION. AND SEEING
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN OPPOSITION I WILL ROOM I'VE
MOVED TO ROOM- ONE TWELFTH. ARE
AGAIN LOOKING AT I KNOW ONE
APPROACHING THE PODIUM. SO
MISTER MODERATOR I'M GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO YOU FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO MIGHT
BE THERE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU REGARD TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO ADD TO
THE QUEUE. THERE WE HAVE KNOWN
OPPOSING AT THIS TIME MA'AM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE WILL TALK WITH YOU
SHORTLY I'M GONNA COME BACK UP-
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE AT THE
DYESS AND ASK IF THERE ARE
FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS. I
WOULD CERTAINLY ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. THANK YOU MR MAJORITY
LEADER MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
EIGHTH. I AYE HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG LAYERED HI AYE WILK
HI LOOK AYE ATKINS HI I CAN
SIDE RIGHT IT IS UNANIMOUS MISS
COOPER THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
YOUR ATTENTION AND FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THAT THANK YOU LET ME
SEE I SEE A FAR STERNER
REFERRED WOULD LIKE A BREAK.
IT'S WE WILL TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
THANK YOU.
I WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE APPOINTMENTS OF TWO
MEMBERS OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE APPEALS BOARD- MISTER
MICHAEL J. ALLEN IS WITH US AND
LOWER EAST CAN'T MANI. WELCOME
TO BOTH OF YOU. I WILL. GOOD TO
SEE YOU- WE MAKE SURE I SEE
MISTER ALAN. OKAY SO WELCOME TO
BOTH OF YOU WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THE END
INTRODUCTIONS OF MR ALLEN AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO MISS CAN'T
MONEY TO DO THE SAME. AFTER
EACH OF YOU'VE GIVEN YOUR-
INTRODUCTIONS YOUR HELLOS IN
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS FEEL FREE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE I WILL THEN COME
BACK TO MEMBERS AND COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS AND WITH THAT.
WILL BEGIN WITH YOU MISTER
ALLEN IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU- GO
RIGHT AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
PRESIDENT PRO TEM ATKINS IN
ARBIL SENATORS- FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO THANK- THE COMMITTEE
AND ON THE STAFF OF OUR- FOR
THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE ASKED
DURING THE TIME OF THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS- REGARDING THE
C. Y. B. C. U. I. B. AS THE
CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE APPEALS BOARD. FOR
THE STENOGRAPHER AND- THE
QUESTIONS WERE BEING ASKED I
THOUGHT WERE REALLY VERY GOOD
BECAUSE THEY WERE TRYING TO
TRULY UNDERSTAND WHAT WE DO
BOB. OUT WHICH IN STATE
GOVERNMENT WHAT IS OUR ROLE AND
I THERE WAS A LOT OF GENUINE
CURIOSITY AS TO HOW WE DO OUR
WORK SO I THOUGHT IT WAS
REALLY. THOUGHTFUL AND. GOOD
DAY INTERVIEW PROCESS. I WANT
TO TELL YOU STREET TO GOALS ARE
FOR THIS YEAR AND B. FOR TWO
NINETEEN INTO TWENTY TWO FOR
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS. IT SOUNDS
SIMPLE BUT ACTUALLY ARE OF. A
LOT OF HARD WORK GOES INTO THEM
FOR OUR APPEAL DECISIONS. OF WE
HAD A DOCTOR MODEL OF FAST FAIR
AND FRIENDLY. REGARDING THE
PARTIES APPEAR BEFORE INSTANCE
FOR JUSTICE AND DUE PROCESS FOR
ALL. FISCAL STEWARDSHIP AND
COMMITMENT TO A TRAINED AND
SKILLED WORKFORCE. IN MY ROLE
AS A BOARD MEMBER- I TRY TO OUR
USE OF THE TOUCHED ON THE CORE
VALUES OF THE C. O. A. B. AND
THOSE THOSE ARE CORE VALUES.
ARE A QUALITY SERVICE.
RESPECTABLE UP TO ALL INTEGRITY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. I'M I'M THE%
LONGEST SERVING BOARD MEMBER
NOW I AM ACTUALLY THE LAST
REMAINING BOARD MEMBER WHO
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCED THE GREAT
RECESSION AND THE CRISIS IN THE
MARGINS THE SITUATION WE HAD
DURING THAT THAT GREAT DOWNTURN
OF THE ECONOMY AND- THAT
EXPERIENCE HAS UP. TO ALLOWED
ME TO BASICALLY FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD. SHOULD BE- THE
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY FOR THE
BOARD AND- DURING THIS TIME
I'VE BEEN VERY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE WONDERFUL COLLEAGUES HAVE
COME UNDER THE BOARD AND I'VE
BEEN THERE. DR PROVIDE ADVICE-
OF. ANY KIND OF- OF INFORMATION
THEY NEED. I CALLED THE
UNWRITTEN PROTOCOLS IN TERMS OF
HOW HOW DO YOU NAVIGATE AN
AGENCY AND I GET YOUR QUESTION
VAST WHO DO YOU GO TO FOR WHAT
YOU NEED. AND- I'M VERY PROUD
OF THAT SERVICE- SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS I WORKED ON
BESIDES EDUCATING THOUSANDS OF
CASES OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS
YES- BECAUSE I KNEW THE BOARD
MEMBER WHO WAS THERE DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION. I DID A LOT OF
TALKING WITH STAFF AND A
VETERANS OF THE AGENCY TO FIND
OUT. WHAT NEEDED TO BE DONE TO
BE READY FOR THE NEXT. DOWNTURN
OF FOR THE ECONOMY OR OR NUMBER
JINSHI SITUATION AND BASICALLY
FINDING OUT THOSE THOSE ISSUES
I WAS ABLE TO FOR INSTANCE OUT
WORK WITH WITHOUT MY COLLEAGUES
AND MANAGEMENT. OUR TOP
MANAGEMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO STAFF UP RAPIDLY
BY HAVING A CURRENT- ELEGY TO
OUR EMPLOYMENT LIST BE FRESH
AND AVAILABLE FOR HIRING. TO BE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH RELATIONSHIP
WITH OTHER AGENCIES WELL WE
COULD BORROW ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES. AND ARE SURE TO
ESSENTIALLY. OF BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL THE RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED SUCH AS IS GOOD
COMMUNICATION WITH THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR WHICH OF
FUNDS 90% OF OUR OPERATIONS
WERE WERE ESTABLISH ALIGNMENT
WAS PRE PLANNING AND GOOD
COMMUNICATION. GOING FORWARD.
INTO MY GOALS FOR THIS COMING
TERM ARE TWO. OF NUMBER ONE UP.
GIVEN THAT WERE IN THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND PANDEMIC
IS TO PUT. IS TO PRESERVE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND SECURITY.
OF OUR THE PUBLIC IN OUR WORK
FORCE. AND ALSO TO EXERCISE
GOOD JUDGMENT WITH THE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES OF OUR
AGENCY. TO WORK WITH MY BOARD
COLLEAGUES AND MANAGEMENT TO A
COMPLETE THIS YEAR MIGHT BE A
MODERNIZATION PROCESS FOR FIRST
LEVEL APPEALS WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE ST ON THE SECOND
LEVEL APPEALS WE HAD ALREADY
MODERNIZE THE SECULAR WORLD
PEELS OF THE BOARD APPEALS THE
FIRST LEVEL APPEALS ARE THE ONE
TO GO TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES. AND I WOULD CERTAINLY
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THE EXCELLENT WORK
OF ALL OUR JUDGES. ARE SUPPORT
STAFF MY BOARD COLLEAGUES AND-
THE LEADERSHIP OF CHAIR BLOCK
IT'S BEEN DOING INCREDIBLY GOOD
JOB FOR OUR AGENCY. IN
CONCLUSION I JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. AND
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION WE WILL CERTAINLY
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION WITH THE HELP OF
OUR STAFF SO I JUST DONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR HERE.
TODAY IN FRONT OF YOU THANK YOU
MISTER ALLEN. I MISS CAN'T
MONEY. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
PRESIDENT PRO TEM AND SENATORS.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
I AM HONORED TO HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR NEW SOME
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE APPEALS
BOARD AND TO SERVE CALIFORNIANS
DURING THE SOME PRESIDENTE TIME.
I WANT TO THANK BRIEFLY MY
FAMILY FOR THEIR SUPPORT MY
PARENTS AND SISTER I'M
ESPECIALLY MY HUSBAND AND OUR
THREE CHILDREN. IN MY TEN
MONTHS AS A BOARD MEMBER I HAVE
DRAWN HEAVILY FROM MY
BACKGROUND IN IMMIGRATION LAW
REPRESENTING WORKING
CALIFORNIANS. FROM THIS
EXPERIENCE I TRULY UNDERSTAND
THAT EACH CASE I ROLL ON AS A
BOARD MEMBER. HAS A REAL LIFE
IMPACT ON A WORKER AND EMPLOYER
AND THIS IS A CHARGE I DO NOT
TAKE LIGHTLY. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY FELLOW BOARD
MEMBERS AND THE JUDGES AND
STAFF THROUGHOUT OUR AGENCY FOR
THEIR DEDICATION AND HARD WORK
DURING THIS CHALLENGING TIME.
WHEN I BEGAN ON THE BOARD IT
WAS VERY CLEAR THAT BECAUSE OF
THE HARD WORK IMMEDIATELY WHEN
THE PANDEMIC CAN'T OUR AGENCY%
WAS ABLE TO PIVOT. AND CONDUCT
ALL OF OUR HEARINGS VIA
TELEPHONE. WE ALSO BEGAN HIRING
IMMEDIATELY ADDITIONAL JUDGES
AND STAFF IN PHASES. TO MANAGE
TO INCREASE CASELOAD THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED- ALLEN MENTIONED WE
ARE FORTUNATE THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE IN THE PIPELINE AND
APPEALS MODERNIZATION PROJECT
IN UNDER WAY THAT IS EXPECTED
TO LAUNCH LATER THIS YEAR AND
ONCE IT DOES. ALL PARTIES WILL
HAVE INSTANT ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR PENDING
APPEALS WHICH IS GOING TO BE A
HUGE IMPROVEMENT FOR
CALIFORNIANS. A FEW OF MY GOALS
FOR THE REMAINDER OF MY TERM
OUR TO CONTINUE ASSURING THAT
WE PROVIDE ALL PARTIES WITH
FULL AND FAIR HEARINGS AND
PROMPTLY ADJUDICATE THEIR
APPEALS. TO PROVIDE WHERE WE'RE
ABLE TO CLARIFYING GUIDANCE IN
THE DECISIONS THAT WE ISSUE.
AND TO EXPAND LANGUAGE ACCESS
IN CONJUNCTION WITH OUR
MODERNIZED APPEAL SYSTEM. WITH
THAT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH I AM
GOING TO START WITH SENATOR
BASS. YOUR MATE YES WE CAN'T-
BUT SOMETHING BLOCKING MY
SCREEN HERE. CONGRATULATIONS
MISTER ALLEN AND NELSON- COUNTY
MINING- YOU ALL HAVE A AN
INCREDIBLE JOB COMING FRIEND OF
YOU BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WITH
ALL THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE HAD
IDEA EVD AND GETTING YOU IBM HE
WAY ALLEN BALLOT IN THIS. VERY
VERY ON TRYING TIME. AND YOU
HAVE A GUY YOU HAVE HUGE BUT
YOU'RE- ARE VERY REASSURING YOU
DO YOU HAVE ARE YOUR HEART AND
SOUL INTO REPRESENTING
CERTAINLY THE AGENCY BUT LITTLE
SLOW INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE BEEN SO.
INTERFACE SUCH DIFFICULT
SITUATION HIDING WITH THEIR ON
AN EMPLOYMENT CLAIMS THAT
CENTER I DO HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF BOTH OF YOU. ARE BASED ON
YOUR PRESENTATION AND YOUR
EXPERIENCE BUT A QUESTION IT
WAS VERY INTERESTING IN
ARNOLD'S LOSES THEIR JOB YOU
WERE GETTING A BETTER INTENT OF
THE MEETING SIR YOU'RE
TELECONFERENCING. AND THAT IS
EXCITING BECAUSE THAT MEANS
THERE'S A REAL INTERACTION
DIALOGUE THAT GOES ON AND
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT EACH OTHER
THAT PEOPLE FEEL THAT THEY'RE
CARED ABOUT AND NOT THERE THEIR
ISSUES ARE REALLY BEING
ADDRESSED ON. IN A VERY
RESPONSIBLE WAY BUT THE
QUESTION IS WILL LET YOU
CONTINUE THAT WILL YOU HAVE AN
IDEA OF IT MAYBE EXPANDING AT
TO ZOOM. ZOOM GIVES THAT TO
BACK AND FORTH SEEING PEOPLE
YOU KNOW AND NOT QUITE IN
PERSON BUT CLOSE TO THAT-
CERTAINLY EXPANDS OF THE
FEELING THAT OF BEING
RESPECTED. IN THE BUREAUCRACY
SOMETIMES PEOPLE FEEL A
GOVERNMENT JUST HAVE THEIR THEY
NOD THEIR HEAD THAT THEY DON'T
REALLY HAVE THEIR EARS OPEN OR
THEIR HEARTS SO. WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHT ON BOTH OF THOSE ITEMS
HELLO MORE TELECONFERENCING AND
PERHAPS EXPANDING. ON TOO SOON
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE. THIS YEAH
MAYBE AFTER THE FIRST JOB MARCH
ON THE ON THE ANSWER YOU KNOW
WHAT I THINK OF WERE NOT WHAT
ARE OUR NEW SCHOOL TO BE WE
DON'T KNOW BECAUSE NOW WITH
THAT'S GOING TO IN THE FEW. BUT
I DO THINK THAT AND I DISCUSS
ABOUT MODERNIZING THE AGENCY
AND BEING- I'M MORE ACCESSIBLE
IT'S THE SORT OF THING WHERE
WERE OPENED USING ALL THE
TECHNOLOGIES YOU KNOW- FOR MANY
YEARS AT LEAST 70% OF ALL OR
APPEALS WERE IN PERSON AND- IT
HAS MADE IT NOW MORE ACCESSIBLE
WHAT WE'RE DOING. BUT IT'S MY
FEELING THAT. WE WILL- I GUESS
IS TRUE FOR NOT ONLY CAN WE DO
MORE THINGS AND DO THEM
DIFFERENTLY IN THE FUTURE WE'RE
STILL FIGURING THAT OUT BUT THE
ONE THING THAT I WANTED TO ALSO
MENTION IS THAT WE ALSO REALIZE
THERE'S MANY PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO BROADBAND WHO DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO SOME OF THE
EQUIPMENT AND PROGRAMS AND
THINGS THAT WE HAVE SO THAT. WE
ARE WE ARE BEING VERY CAREFUL
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN STILL
SEE A KEEP A PAPER CAPACITY
FROM CAPACITY DO YOU KNOW LOW
TECH CAPACITY FOR THOSE FOLKS
WE'RE NOT FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
BE ABLE TO USE THE EQUIPMENT
THAT OF MANY OTHER CLAIMANTS
WILL SO- I'LL I'LL LEAVE IT TO
MY COLLEAGUES TO ALSO AWAITING
HERE BUT THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS.
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD MISCON. GO
AND BUILD ON WHAT- MEMBER ALLEN
SAID AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR BATES. WE HAVE
HAD DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW WHEN
YOU TRY TO LOOK AT THE SILVER
LINING OF A SITUATION LIKE
THIS. ONE BENEFIT IS REALIZING.
ADDITION INCREASED
PARTICIPATION WHEN YOU OFFER
ADDITIONAL AVENUES FOR PEOPLE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
SO ABSOLUTELY WE WANT TO
CONTINUE EXPLORING WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. IN CONJUNCTION WITH
OUR APPEALS MODERNIZATION
PROJECT. AND ONE THING THAT WE
KNOW AS WELL FOR SOME PEOPLE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE STILL MEANS
BEING IN PERSON WITH A JUDGE
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE
ADDED LAYERS LIKE AN
INTERPRETER. SOME OF THOSE
THINGS GET LOST IN TRANSLATION
WITH THE PHONE- BUT CERTAINLY
MODALITIES LIKE ZOOM ARE STILL
OFFERING TO PEOPLE ONCE IT'S
SAFE TO HAVE THEIR DAY IN
COURT. REALLY BE IN PERSON. WE
WOULD LIKE TO JUST HAVE
ADDITIONAL AVENUES FOR PEOPLE
SO THAT THEY HAVE. THE OPTION
TO DO WHATEVER IS BEST FOR THEM.
THANK YOU FOR. ANSWERS AND
UNION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE CONGRADULATIONS
STANDUP. YOU WILL HAVE MY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MAJORITY LEADER.
CONGRADULATIONS NO QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ADOPTED
JUST BECAUSE BOTH THE MILITANTS
OF THE MEETING THANK YOU MR
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM AND-
CONGRATULATIONS- TO BOTH YOU
FOR YOUR APPOINTMENT AND
REAPPOINTMENT- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR CONFIRMATION
TODAY- MISS CAN'T MONEY DID DID
MENTION THE- UPCOMING I. T.
PROGRAM. I SPENT FOUR YEARS ON
BUDGET SUB FOR STATE
ADMINISTRATION AND I'M VERY
WARY SKEPTICAL- THE I. T.
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE SO I'M
JUST WONDERING YOU MENTIONED
COMING ONLINE LATER THIS YEAR I
JUST CARE SAID WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE AND I WANT YOU GUYS CAN
ANSWER IT AND- I DON'T EVEN
BOTH OF YOU. WHICH IS WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE EFFICIENCIES THAT
YEAH YOU ALL HOPE TO ACHIEVE
THROUGH THE NEW PROGRAM. WELL
FIRST OF ALL- I WAS SMILING AS
YOU BROUGHT THIS UP BECAUSE I
KNOW WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE OF
WHAT CAN GO WRONG WITH I. T.
BUT I'D LIKE TO ASSURE YOU
THAT. ESSENTIALLY ALL THE I. T.
THAT WE'RE USING AS OFF THE
SHELF. AND WHAT WE'RE DOING AS
WE ARE BUILDING THE SYSTEM.
WOULD YOU IN WHAT ARE CALLED
SPRINTS WHERE WE KEEP ON
TESTING EACH PART OF THE SYSTEM
AS WE BUILD IT AND GO FORWARD.
AND SO- IT'S NOT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING NO OVER RUNS WHAT
WE'RE VERY CONFIDENT. HE SAID
OF THIS FINGERS CROSSED THAT IT
WILL BE ON ON THE ONLINE. BY
SUMMER. BUT I THINK THAT WHAT
ALSO IS VERY GOOD IS THAT. ARE
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN INTERNAL
NEWSLETTER- WHERE I'M THE
EDITOR WITH MY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE. LARA WE ARE
HAVE BEEN KEEPING SHELVE A
PRIZE OF THE MODERNIZATION
PROCESS AND EACH CHANGE.
ANYTHING THAT'S OF TROUBLING OR
PROBLEM IS FIXED AT THAT STAGE
BEFORE WE GO ONLINE. SO CAN I
CAN I PROMISE WILL BE FLAWLESS
IN THE BEGINNING NOW. BUT I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS
TO BE OPTIMISTIC THAT IT'S
GOING TO SERVE. REALLY A GREAT
BENEFIT TO THE PUBLIC- GOING
FORWARD AND DOWN. I DON'T.
RELEASED MY INITIAL COMMENTS ON
IT. MAYBE MEMBER KEN BODY WITH
TO ADD. THANK YOU I'LL KEEP IT
BRIEF I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THE
END GOAL IS TO REALLY BE
PROVIDE ACCESS TO ALL OF THE
PARTIES SO LOOKING AT A PORTAL
THAT PEOPLE CAN USE TO GET
IMMEDIATE ACCESS ABOUT THEIR
PENDING APPEAL WHICH ESPECIALLY
IN THIS CLIMATE WILL BE.
EXTREMELY HELPFUL FOR ALL
PARTIES WHO ARE ANXIOUSLY
AWAITING THE DETERMINATION OF
THEIR CASE AND WE ARE ASSURED
EVERY MONTHS WITH UPDATES FROM
OUR MANAGEMENT- AND WE KNOW
THAT AS OF NOW THE I. T.
PROJECT IS ON BUDGET AND ON
TIME. AND IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
EVERYONE IS WORKING REALLY HARD
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE REACH THE
END GOAL. GRANT PRECIADO THE
ANSWERS FROM BOTH YOU AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU. ARE
CENTER LAYERED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BOB I HAD A GREAT JIM R.
WITH BOTH OF MOVES WELL IN. THE
HOURS LATE AND THEY WENT ON THE
RECORD WITH US EVERYTHING I
WOULD BY WORD OF JUST FOR THE
PURPOSES OF. OF DRAWING IT OUT
FAST. MISS CAN'T MONNING A
QUESTION BECAUSE SHE'S. WALL
SENATOR BATES ASKED ABOUT THE
CONSTITUENCY GROUPS HERE AND
WHAT THE RESPONSE HAS BEEN TO
COBRA DID HOW THEY'VE
RESPONDED- SHE HAS BEEN
AFFECTED IN THAT SHE WAS
APPOINTED JUST. AS THE PANDEMIC
IN THE LOCKDOWN HAPPENED AND SO
SHE INDICATED TO ME. THAT ONE
OF THE FIRST THING SHE WANTED
TO DO IS AN APPOINTEE. IS
FINALLY BE ABLE TO GO TO THE
DIFFERENT OFFICES AND MEET THE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE ACROSS. OF THE
AGENCY AND- I COULD HAVE GIVEN
HER THE BENEFIT TO PUT THAT ON
THE RECORD HERSELF BUT I JUST
THOUGHT I WOULD MENTION IT AND-
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I'M GOING
TO BE VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
BOTH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU BOTH. I
AM GOING TO GO TO- MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC LET ME OUR REMIND
FOLKS- FOR WITNESSES WISHING TO
PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE. THAT
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS. NINE TWO
FOUR ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT IT IS
ON THE SCREEN IN FRONT OF ME
NOW. SO WE WILL BEGIN- WITH
ANYONE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE WHO'S HERE IN
SUPPORT- SEEING NO MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC HERE LET ME JUST
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND
MAKE SURE OKAY WE HAVE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. SO LET ME- RETURN TO
OUR MODERATOR ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. AND ASK IF
THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN
PROP TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YET
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME FROM THE
PHONE LINES ONE ZERO. THANK YOU.
I'M SURE WE HAVE NO ONE FROM
THE PHONE LINES OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR WILL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU IN A
MOMENT. LET ME TURN TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO MIGHT BE HERE
IN OPPOSITION AGAIN COMING BACK
TO ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
THERE ARE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PRESENT. LOOKING AGAIN
AT ROOM ONE TWELVE I STILL SEE
NO ONE- APPROACHING THE PODIUM
SO MISTER MODERATOR I'M GONNA
COME BACK TO YOU FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO MAY BE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK
GOD TO OPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE
THANK ZERO BACK TO THE QUEUE.
MADAM CHAIR WE ARE GOING TO
KILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE APPRECIATE YOUR
HELP TODAY MADAM CHAIR I WOULD
MOVE BOTH APPOINTMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I. NO OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAYER. LET
ME ASK YOU TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MADAM SECRETARY. IT'S. I
BELIEVE I HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE THERE HI I WILL
HI LOOK AYE ATKINS AYE A
CONCISE UNANIMOUS AND LET ME
JUST SAY BOTH OF YOU HAVE
ENOUGH EXPERIENCE TO KNOW THAT
THESE DON'T ALWAYS GO SO
SMOOTHLY SO I THINK THAT'S A
TRIBUTE TO THE WORK THAT YOU'REDOING AND THE CONFIDENCE PEOPLE
HAVE SO CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE ALL OF YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU MICHAEL.
OKAY LET ME SAY THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY. TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US. AND WE
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE FILE THE OFFICIAL ARE
HEARING RECORDS SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU EVERYONE THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES IS NOW
ADJOURNED. GREAT JOB PROGRAMS.
IT.